hello welcome to this video playing
Grand Master mandragora this is Grand
Master Gao Qi block from usually from
Germany but he's living in Thailand now
for quite a long while Bishop c4 the
funky move here sorry why God to kill
them kill the signal ok so I'm going to
open up the position here a little bit
b6 is not my regular repertoire but I
wanted to do something something else
check uh-huh hmm interesting can I get
rid of that Bishop here or is that too
weird let's do that it looks weird but
I've got my fair share of bad French
games to appreciate that getting rid of
that Bishop can be a good thing
interesting haha ok come on check let's
get rid of that
it so it's sometimes just a nice feeling
that you and after like seven or eight
moves you have a position where you can
be reasonably sure that this was never
ever ever played in a game before yeah
you just done complete completely new
territory okay I'm going for a quick
c-5m mm take on Bishop t2 or something
like that I don't know well c 5 is not
big deal maybe I can just go nite bd2 if
he likes this one hmm yeah night c4 is
probably not not that great anyway and
am I going back to be seven that's a
weird spot well the two is also weird
spot hmm I don't know not very satisfied
with that
I wonder if he should shoot for
something like yeah exactly yeah what
can you do is a good player yeah former
teammate of mine before he decided to
move to a somewhat warmer country in
Asia okay so what now do I go see six
that looks kind of passer but I don't
know maybe it's maybe not so bad
position fields reasonably solid even
though my night on b7 is just an
amazingly stupid looking piece yeah here
maybe I can do Knight a5 c6 back taking
on a five it's not something to be
feared and so and that a six poorness is
always under pressure
would have liked can I go now cannot I
would like to go b5 somehow but I don't
don't see this ever happening and he if
he gets in b5 that's that's a big
problem yeah I'm simply terrible in
French French type positions I mean it's
a cannot play those I simply cannot i
always get this kind of a kind of bad
passive position I'm just bad I'm just
bad at it what can I really don't know
what to do and ok ok so maybe we should
be five Adam nita I don't want to see
maybe i can get be five in 93 i might be
able to take on before but it's got 90
xt5 even that is possible my other idea
is to Queen B 7 rook c8 maybe i can
trade enough things so that it's not
that terrible i am he wants to go to see
one okay so i go b5 him
yeah I Scott Quincy one next sister this
is the issue just amazingly passive so
what to do rooks is seven I would need a
bishop on the aid to to somehow stop
that for the moment all right on b8
knight on c6 but that's difficult to get
well it's just just a remarkably bad
position how do I gain how do I do this
can I somehow now just Quincy one I mean
it's got vogue theatre oxy seven and
both both is a big issue k if he goes
rook c7 I could be shipped e8 which is I
mean but yeah just not very inspiring
quite obviously
can I have some all regroup stuff maybe
this 96 97 this would be nice I should
have done that hi morning should have
done that earlier one thing is he can
maybe take on age six of course that
that could be something yeah page five
h5 is the problem
but if he goes 95 there is no direct
threat at least or is it I don't see a
direct threat now you'll see a drug
maybe just does it take a six year maybe
he does but I've got Roxy to check maybe
I can enter Quincy for queen everyone
let's do that I have to gamble a little
bit gem check I don't believe any of
that what's that really so bad i think i
missed some chances i'm pretty sure
about it check general Wang check check
it's not even clear this position even
though I'm a queen up I mean he's got
million millions of pawns I think I'm
just lost him now I'm just lost for like
funny girls on time no I already lost
some time that was just too bad i mean i
don't think that this was a correct
sacrifice in terms of winning but it's
just a terrible position to play yeah
yeah here black wins but it's well but
it's difficult it's difficult so what
does win Queens is seven Quincy three
wins yeah why doesn't have an attack
here but well I had to add to just go
ahead and fire so that also just wind
rupee two wins that also wins chan it's
minus a million with with Queen d3
threatening made yeah and I'm winning
pretty easily yeah that's pretty simple
I could have already could have seen
that it's not not not that difficult
yeah queen bee three is two wins this
losses due to be 70 quindi three wins
for made I didn't see that that's made
on f5 this is a ship yeah I've didn't
play that well anyway Jim check yeah
here white wins even though I get the
Queen check it doesn't matter anything I
mean this king is perfectly safe and
he's got this this ape horn oh man yeah
I just had a terrible position from the
from the get-go I simply cannot play
this stuff I simply cannot I mean it's
quite funny that the engine doesn't even
like wide that much and gives a wide a
slight edge yet after that it's a
it's maybe some some kind of draw but
hmm tough to say okay thanks for
watching